all right also developing tonight with
just days until the virginia's
governor's race republican glenn younkin
has all the momentum a new fox news poll
shows young can up a whopping eight
points over the struggling mcauliffe and
remember just two weeks ago that same
poll mcauliffe was up five a massive
shift
and the mcauliffe campaign
they are showing more and more signs of
desperation as new emails reveal a
botched effort to kill a fox news story
about mcauliffe hiring clinton lawyer
mark elias to possibly challenge the
election results here to break down the
state of the race the race rnc
chairwoman ronna mcdaniel
along with fox news contributor charlie
hurt thank you both for joining us rana
you got your ears to the ground
understand what's going on there in
virginia what's the latest from your
vantage point
well glenn younkin is running a
virginia-focused race he's focusing on
education lowering taxes
making sure that we back the blue
lowering crime rates and mcauliffe is
floundering he's bringing in all his dc
swamp friends stacy abrams kamala harris
biden he's result resorting to terrible
tactics in this race and the virginia
people are looking at young and yonkin
and they're recognizing that he is a
candidate that will represent them and
do good things for virginia and that's
why he's surging
and charlie you know they're my
understanding of the race they're trying
to nationalize it but i think the people
of virginia are smart enough to figure
out that things like education are
really important and that the governor
actually does have a say in it
uh what you're you're a virginian yeah
uh give us your perspective
yeah it's it's really the the
desperation on the part of terry
mcauliffe is is truly palpable in
virginia right now um they you know and
as uh you know
it's kind of uh it's sort of amazing to
step back and think about the fact that
uh forever for so long education has
been sort of a strong point for
democrats and it's been the issue that
democrats have have uh managed to win on
and for for terry mcauliffe to turn this
around and allowed education to become
the issue the singular issue that is
unifying republicans and that glenn
younkin is using to very much surge here
at the end and i think probably wind up
winning comfortably i think it's a i
think it's a new day in virginia and i
think it's a new day
i think it'll be a new day outside of
virginia once
democrats in washington realize what
what their voters in richmond in in
virginia think of of uh these crazy
policies
now rana um
the presidential election uh joe biden
won virginia by 10 points
but it's really those people that are
the true centrists right the people that
are in the middle the the unaffiliated
that are swaying hard to the right in
this in this election
yeah virginia's a blue state you've got
a democrat governor two democrat
senators biden one by ten but it is moms
moms like me
in blue states who were watching our
kids be shut out of the classroom who
were on the front lines of those zoom
classes and working to get them educated
through this pandemic and be insulted by
someone like mcauliffe to say parents
have no say in their kids education as
we have been the ones going through this
day after day with our kids as they
suffered not being in the classroom not
being with their friends dealing with
the pandemic it has really awakened
parents in these suburbs of virginia and
that's why you're seeing the mcauliffe
surge but it's going to take everyone
getting out and vote everyone needs to
vote we need a strong election day
turnout and every republican everywhere
in virginia needs to get a friend and go
to the polls on tuesday
yeah i i think there are a lot of people
who
they've made up their mind but they need
to get out and vote and if they're
afraid that the vote's already done the
last few days has a lot of stupid
shenanigans in it but showing up and
actually voting is what it all comes
down to charlie
yeah absolutely and i think it's really
also very interesting to look at the
cast of characters that terry mcauliffe
has dragged into the state to campaign
with him he can't campaign alone
apparently he can't make the deal and to
look across the other way and you see
glenn younkin standing there by himself
campaigning on his own
making his case to voters and as ronna
points out i think i think virginia
voters do appreciate that and i also
think it's interesting that terry
mcauliffe he and joe biden when joe
biden went went into the state
earlier this week all they could talk
about was donald trump that's all they
wanted to talk about they didn't whether
they can't talk about the issues and
they can't talk about the person they're
running against because he's running a
great campaign and he has identified
issues that that voters care about a lot
more than whatever it is that terry
mcauliffe is afraid to talk about
yeah younkin has run a very impressive
race and stayed so focused on the issues
that people actually really care about
isn't it amazing when you talk about
issues and you talk about what actually
affects people you win elections and uh
that's what i think we're in the midst
of seeing right now thank you both
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else